Hey Everyone Diavolo here and in todays video we
are going to be going over ANOTHER of the most
anticipated fights in all of Jujutsu kaisen. This
here is the two fights that take place between
the FREAKING MONOLITHS OF OPPOSITE STRENGTHS
IN THE SERIES. A Seemingly infinite amount of
cursed energy with the prodigy himself Saturo
Gojo and his SIX EYES vs the MOST FEARED MAN,
YES JUST A MAN WITH NO CURSED ENERGY AT ALL
in the history Of Jujutsu Kaisen, That being
the assassin Toji Fushiguro… But just before we
get into the video, if you are new around here
and want to watch similar explained content for a
multitude of different series, then make sure to
hit that subscribe button and leave a like as it
really helps out with that ole YouTube algorithm.
PLUS im only like 7k subs away from 100k
SO ITD BE ABSOLUTELY INSANE IF WE COULD
REACH THAT BEFORE THE END OF DECEMBER.
<3 Anyway enough of that, I need to give
ya’ll a slight bit of pretense around how
we've made it to this exact moment here.
So straight after the events with the cursed
womb death paintings Gojo ends up having a
little bit of a nana nap where he reminisces over
his time in Jujutsu high 11 years earlier! Btw if
you want to watch a full rundown of this arc
and haven't already watched it ill leave the
link to my video down in the description
for ya'll. Pretty much though in short,
the strongest duo, big Geto and Gojo are
tasked with an extremely special mission
which is to transport something called the
Star Plasma Vessel whos actually a chick
called Riko Amanai to Master Tengen so that he
can merge into that persons body and maintain the
hold he has over jujutsu highs concealment
barriers and what not. But enough of that,
So we actually start out on the FINAL day
or day three of the Star Plasma Vessel
Escort mission as the team finally reaches
Tokyo Jujutsu High through the foothills of
Mount Mushiro. They travel up a large
set of stairs through several parallel
torii gates. Then finally reaching the
top of the staircase Geto announces
that they've now made it inside of the
school's barrier cementing their safety.
Riko and Kuroi are both relieved
and everyone thanks Satoru for his
hard work. Tired from the extended
periods keeping the Infinity active,
Satoru ignores the praise and says cheekily
says that the babysitting is finally over.
As soon as Satoru deactivates the
Infinity and lets his guard down, a
katana suddenly pierces through his torso held
by no one other than DEMON LORD HIMSELF Toji
Fushiguro. Everyone initially stands around
utterly confused as they're supposed to be
hidden inside the Jujutsu High's barrier
now. Looking over his shoulder a confused
Satoru asks if he knows him from somewhere, but
Toji tells him not to worry about remembering a
random dudes name. Looking at him, Gojo slightly
recognizes Toji because earlier on in life while
still with the Zenin family Toji once went to
see the Young prodigy, he was a big deal EVEN
BACK THEN and was the first and last person to
EVER notice Toji's presence while out of the
line of site… Back in reality Toji reveals he had
waited until Gojo was worn down to strike stabbing
him from behind in a complete surprise. To try
get away Satoru forces himself up into the air
while Suguru summons his giant man eating curse to
devour Toji. Instantly after securing him, Suguru
rushes to his friend's side but Gojo assures him
that his wound isn't too severe as the moment he
was stabbed he reinforced himself with cursed
energy to reduce taking any further damage..
Gojo asks Geto to take Riko out of the area as he
tries to quickly deal with this random assassin..
Suguru, Riko and Masato then leave the area as
Toji slashes his way out of the giant hookworm
curse and exercises it with a new Katana
that his slippery little curse feed to him.
Toji looks around for the Vessel, but Satoru
tells him that the bounty has already been
lifted. However, its then revealed through
Toji that he was actually the person who
set everything up in the first place. He
used the original payment that was given
to him by the star religious group to hire
a plethora of different assassins to wear
down Gojo’s six eyes so eventually he would
let his guard down and through that he would
create some sort of opening… WHICH IS SO BIG
BRAIN, LIKE THIS IS WHY TOJI IS A GOAT. YEAH
HE GOT THE CASH MONEYS FOR DOING THIS JOB, BUT
HIS ULTIMATE GOAL IS A PERSONAL ACHEIVEMENT OF
TAKING DOWN THE HEIGHT OF CURSED ENERGY SO THAT
HE HIMSELF FEELS FULLFILLED.. HE IS A MONSTER
Battle
Satoru understands Toji's plan and begins his
offensive by generating a field of attraction
behind his opponent to send him flying away
using the illustrious Cursed Technique Lapse:
Blue! However, Toji is incredibly
fast and his reflexes are just
utterly superior to the younger Gojo's.
He's able to not only avoid the attack,
but instantly covers enough ground to move
from where he is to a roof behind Satoru..
This makes Gojo realize that Toji has absolutely
zero cursed energy meaning he's using nothing
but an innate physical prowess to fight..
MAN ONLY GOT THEM PURE STRENGTH GAINS!!
Toji switches out his cursed tools and blitzes
Satoru using a random jagged path too fast for
anyone to even follow with the naked eye. Toji
then gets in extremely close and goes to slices
his opponent, yet Satoru manages to blasts
him back with blue, sending him shooting into
a building… once he advances he recognizes that
his opponent knows about the limitless technique
and likely has a plan. Toji then Vanishes
from Gojo’s sight into the nearby buildings
and due to the heavenly restriction our
big brain six eyes user can't sense him
at all. Without any other choice left, Satoru
decides to clear the entire area so Toji cant
hide and again uses his Cursed Technique
Lapse Maximum Cursed Energy Output: Blue!!
Doing this Gojo creates a giant field of
attraction energy that tears up all of
the buildings in the area, destroying them
and leaving nowhere left for Toji to hide.
But somehow Toji manages to get around this and
uses a giant swarm of Fly Heads to distract him.
Seeing this Gojo expands the Infinity around
him to keep the curses away and surmises that
Toji is using them like a chaff grenade.
(Which for those unsure a chaff grenade is
simply a cylindrical type of grenade that, upon
exploding, releases thin pieces of electromagnetic
particles. This Chaff interferes with electronic
devices, like laser sensors and radar systems,
so in this case think of Gojo’s infinity
as almost a radar type system he uses to
pick up object.. Because of this Gojo is
completely unable to locate his opponent
and even considers the possibility that the
Sorcerer Killer left to go after his main target.
Due to this he looks in the direction
of where Suguru and the others went,
making a fatal error. In that
moment, Toji instantly appears
behind him from above the swarm of cursed
insects. Gojo notices in time but his six
eyes recognize the different type of curse energy
flowing out of Toji's new curse tool. Because of
this weird feeling Gojo quickly goes on the
defense, but sadly this only seals his fate..
Its explained that this dope ass looking weapon,
which is a special grade cursed tool called the
Inverted Spear of Heaven nullifies the effect of
any cursed technique, even Limitless... togi stabs
Gojo through the neck with the inverted spear
of heaven leaving gojo completely defenseless.
The injured sorcerer desperately reaches for
the dagger as he bleeds from the mouth. But
Toji acts quickly and cuts into Satoru's torso,
then takes out a second knife and finishes the
job by rapidly stabbing Gojo’s leg, forcing
him to collapse directly into being stabbed
through the forehead by Toji's knife. Appearing
to have been brutally ABSOLUTELY DESTROYED, Satoru
lays in a pool of his own blood as Toji claims
he's finally getting back into the groove of
things. SO YEAH CANT REMEMBER IF I SAID BUT,
THIS ISNT EVEN PRIME TOJI. THAT MONSTER COMES
OUT DURING SHIBUYA BUT STILL HE SOMEHOW TOOK DOWN
THE STRONGEST SORCERER AT THAT TIME ON THE PLANET.
Aftermath
soo, well that obviously cant be the end
of the video as we all know big GOJO isn't
actually dead in the current timeline. So if
you do want a more detailed rundown of what
happens in between here and the rematch then be
sure to check out my Gojo Past arc video where
I go over the story before and after this
point up until the Shibuya Incident Arc.
Pretty much all ya’ll need to know is that
Toji manages to complete his mission and
delivered the star plasma vessel to
the Time Vessel Association.. HOWEVER
AS THIS MOFO IS LEAVING THE AREA SOMETHING
HE PROBABLY CANT EVEN COMPREHEND HAPPENS..
Unbelievably he runs into a restored and
awakened Saturo Gojo who’s delirious on
the increase of strength he’s just
achieved. Standing infront of him,
Toji is taken aback to see someone he was sure
he killed not too long ago. Crazed from overusing
both the Six Eyes and the Limitless to defend
himself, Gojo begins explaining about how when
he was the very edge of death he experienced
and understood the core of cursed energy..
Insulted by the idea that he
could've lost already, Toji
takes out the inverted spear
of heaven and claims that the
battle is just beginning Gojo to which
Gojo gets excited agreeing with Toji..
So im pretty sure that Gojo would
have achieved this state some day
even if Toji wasn't the one to bring it
on. BUT we can defiantly thank big Toji
for bringing on the invincibility level aura
that surrounds Gojo in the current timeline..
Battle
Toji attempts to blitz Gojo dashing straight in
and unloading a monstrous left swing but Satoru
who doesn't even seem to be worried is simply
able to levitate above him to avoid it. While
upside down in the air, Satoru uses the same
concept of a reverse cursed technique and flows
the reverse cursed energy into his Limitless,
unleashing the Cursed Technique Reversal: Red!
From the tip of his fingers a massive energywave
shoots forth. As it connects it sends Toji flying
across the area and clean through another
building. Getting up from the hectic attack,
Toji stretches out his arm and confirms that
the energy wave didn't break any of his bones,
he then breaks down each of the logistics
behind the technique of limitless. He goes
over the three main abilities of the
Limitless which he thinks are Infinity,
Red and Blue and takes out a metal chain from his
curse. He connects it to the end of the Inverted
Spear of Heaven and believes the Infinity,
Blue, or Red won't be an issue any longer
with his added range. Toji comes up with a
countermeasure for each but there is still
a heavy uneasiness resting on his shoulders
that he cant seem to shake. He locks eyes with
Satoru and decides to ignore this uneasiness
for now and initiate the battle once more.
As Toji begins to rapidly spin around his new
upgraded weapon, Satoru apologizes to Riko for
not being able to save her, BUT proclaims
that himself alone is "the honored one",
quoting the FREAKING Buddha himself… Toji uses the
chain to tear apart the ground, creating a wave
of debris that forces Satoru higher in the air.
Suddenly, the Inverted Spear of Heaven appears
from the dust cloud right in front of Gojo. Toji
then flicks the chain, sending the cursed tool
flinging directly at Satoru, who isn't moving
quickly enough through the air to avoid it..
As Gojo floats there he thinks that
info on Inherited techniques often
get out between other Sorcerer Families,
so he guesses the assassin is probably
from the Zenin Family. However, there
is even a technique in the Limitless'
arsenal that is only known to a few
even within the PRIZED Gojo Family.
The awakened Limitless user combines both Red
and Blue to unleash the imaginary mass of energy
that erases everything it touches.. THE INFINITE
Hollow Technique: Purple! As the ability fly's out
it instantly connects with the entire left side
of Toji’s torso, vaporizing half of his chest,
breaking his metal chain and ending his
offensive in one motion powerful motion.
Defeated Toji realizes his uneasiness stemmed
from him breaking his own rule. He knows he
should have said that he doesn't work for free
and made a run for it, but the greatest sorcerer
alive stood before him. Like I said earlier, Toji
wanted to discredit it and crush it to spite the
jujutsu world and the Zenin family.. However
Toji’s self-affirmation caused him to deviate
from his true self and at that point he had
already lost.. Unfortunately for him Toji was
unable to put aside his petty pride and because
of that he sealed his fate… Standing over him now,
Gojo asks if Toji has any last words, initially
he claims he doesn't have anything to say however
after a moment he remembers his young son and
tells Gojo how his son Megumi will be sold to
the Zenin family in two or three years and
to do as he pleases with that information…